warner brothers has a batgirl movie
coming out correction
warner brothers had a batgirl movie
coming out warner brothers spent 90
million dollars so far on this batgirl
movie and the batgirl movie was going to
be the first warner brothers movie with
a transgender
leading character
and now they're just going to shelve the
movie apparently destroy the footage the
the actor ivory aquino just wrote an
open twitter thread to the head of
warner brothers said dear mr zazlab i
just read an article on the hollywood
reporter about supposed funeral
screenings of batgirl and the
possibility afterwards that the film
footage would be destroyed
if this is the case uh please please
reconsider this it's the movie is
apparently so bad that not only are they
willing to burn 90 million dollars
they're gonna burn the footage just so
that it never gets out at all here to
help me make sense of this is not only a
really high level extremely insightful
cultural critic but also a a comic book
mogul himself that would be eric july
eric thank you for coming on the show
i appreciate you having me back michael
so eric i i want to get to you in just a
second because you since we last spoke
you have become a major comic book mogul
with millions and millions of dollars in
non-woke comic book sales so we'll get
to that in a second first though you've
got to help me make sense of this i
don't follow the comic book movies i
don't really follow comic books i
certainly don't follow the warner
brothers internal politics so i didn't
know that there was going to be this
batgirl movie
the trade papers are really whining
about this they say batgirl won't be
released in cinemas or on hbo max the 90
million dollar movie was uh reportedly
close to completion when they decided to
shelve it and it features the dc comics
uh first transgender character seems to
me there's some
correlation there am i am i correct
ah you are somewhat uh correct so with a
new transfer of power that we have over
there at warner's because uh 18t sold
off their entertainment assets you have
that warner discovery merger new ceo has
come in and those that new team of
leadership they've asked and shelved a
lot of different things and one of those
of course were bad girl and i think this
is very significant mainly because yeah
of course nobody was really interested
in i don't know how they managed to
spend 90 million dollars on that in in
the first place that to me is impressive
but nobody was really interested in this
old
race-swapped bat girl it was very
predictable of course they always live
with the social justice aspect of it
first this first stat i'm not really the
content but apparently it was so bad
that they were willing to just take the
tax right off of the 90 million uh
dollars and say nobody needs to see that
that is significant because we've seen
companies put out very bad material but
this and we saw some leak not leaks but
you know on set footage
and it looked pretty bad
i mean this had to be impressively bad
they were like no we put this out we're
going to tarnish our brand even more
than what it already is let's make sure
we put that on the shelf to where nobody
can ever see it that that's pretty
significant from a production company
that's a great point because the a lot
of the comic book movies that have come
out recently
they're not exactly casablanca okay
they're not the greatest movies they're
generally formulaic there's a lot of the
woke nonsense in there which people
don't like but they want to see the good
guy blow up the bad guy and smash up a
city so they'll go and see it the
threshold for the quality of movies is
not all that high and yet apparently
batgirl didn't even reach that very
modest threshold and they said it's
better to write this off on our taxes
and burn it than it would be to release
it
that's huge we i don't know i can't
point to a time to where i've seen
something like this happen where it was
almost done like it wasn't like they
were mid-production like it was all it
was basically done the film was
basically done and it was ready to be
put out be a hbo max or whatever
theaters wherever they were going to put
it and they just said no this can't see
the light of day get rid of that and get
it out of my face um but i don't know
i'm not as willing to jump on like so
many other folks are like oh this means
there's going to be a change with dc
comics or warner i think this is more of
the new leadership not seeing really eye
to eye with the direction that the old
leadership was going they're probably
going to still put out their own
nonsense themselves but it just didn't
seem to make a lot of sense but it still
is very significant for a company to
invest that much in this product and
just to say nah
we just can't put it out because i'm
thinking of the the recent woke flops
and even semi-woke flops where you come
out with
a light year and light year they made a
big deal about including a gay kissing
scene and they got rid of tim allen
because tim allen i guess is too
conservative and they release it and
it's just a major disappointment at the
box office every time that they try to
remake a good movie and they say okay
we're going to remake it but here's a
big splash we're going to only use
chicks you know that's going to be our
really imaginative creative decision we
replace all the men the beloved male
characters with women and then they
always flop and no one ever really likes
those movies so
is your contention
that
hollywood is they're not actually
getting the message here this is more of
a kind of internal political power play
or do you think there's some hope that
that these executives are thinking huh
i'd prefer not to keep losing hundreds
of millions of dollars on this woke
nonsense
i i don't think that they're so ready to
change but i do think that there is and
i've made this point before i think
there's a big disconnect between a lot
of even leadership
uh and the executives versus the people
that are like on the ground or the
actual creatives that are that are part
of this they're the ones that aren't
really investing their own money in into
the project i think that executives of
major
entertainment companies have been
convinced that this was the way of the
future and if you looked at twitter or
you looked at tick tock it may have seen
that way that this is what people let's
say want it but when it comes to
customers actually spending their money
and their dollars on certain things or
viewing things you're seeing that that's
simply not the case no matter how many
retweets you get no matter how many
these weird stand accounts that get
created uh it doesn't really matter
they're not necessarily paying willing
customers so i do think that there's
going to be a pivot at
at some point when people continue to
look at the bottom line the executives
do and they're like okay guys we're not
making money you see that i don't know
if you heard about like the cw they got
new ownership or something of that
nature and they just flat out admitted
for a while now they've been operating
at a loss
like that that kind of went under the
radar i was like wow that's pretty
significant like that they were just
making content and weren't it wasn't
that they weren't making profit they
were operating at a loss wow and i think
as more companies start to do that
then you'll see a pivot i just don't
know if we're quite ready which to me is
a beautiful thing because that allows
folks like myself and others to try to
be competitors in this market well you
you are you are a competitor i think
you're probably more than a competitor
so since we last spoke eric you uh you
are the owner of rip averse publishing
you put out this non-woke
comic book
and i thought when i first saw the story
i said eric july man that's cool good
for him i hope he makes a couple bucks
on that that's a good effort you know me
i don't know anything about comics maybe
i'll even buy a copy then i look down
you have made if my numbers are correct
here eric i don't want to out you have
people come hitting you up for cash
you have sold
three and a half million dollars worth
of comic books the number i have in
front of me is you've sold 50 000 copies
pre-sold of your of your comic book
yes that is very true 3.4 million and
that is still i'm trying to get used to
that because
that's a big number but i didn't expect
it i expected it to to be successful
don't get me wrong right i put up
hundreds of thousands of dollars of my
own money to to get this thing off the
ground but i thought of this 45 million
different ways and i would have never
came up with a way that i would hey i'm
gonna make three i would have been like
no there's no way that we do that but
man for us to come out do that to have
over forty thousand purchases over fifty
thousand total uh books
so
to put that like comparably speaking
like looking at
companies if you look at like comic-con
they put out the data for hey diamond
accounted for this many in sales for the
major publishers the top selling graphic
novel last year uh like in argentina
superhero graphic novel was for was uh
like i believe 24 000 copies so to put
that in perspective we destroyed them by
double their their copies and this is
our first book right this is a very
significant thing
and i think that when i came out and
said hey i'm trying to go out there and
actually i think we can make a splash i
think we can be very competitive in this
market i i think people knew it but now
that you see it it's more tangible and
as these books start getting shipped out
going into september uh it becomes more
and more real that holy crap there's a
big
like uh demographic that wants this but
they're more so they're paying customers
yeah i didn't get access the access
media advanced copies i didn't get i
didn't get the coverage from the big uh
comic book in fact the ones that did
cover us was were writing hit pieces
about us we didn't have any of that we
just did it organically and we again
accounted for more than 50 000. um it
just goes to show just how thriving this
market can be if you simply just market
it well and give people what they want
who buys comic books i maybe this is
probably my own naivete i i don't know
that i've ever read a complete comic
book in my life i've read parts of them
i've been given comic books and i'm not
saying i didn't enjoy them i just in my
mind this was a really relatively small
market i didn't i assumed it went woke
just like every other entertainment
medium went woke and then so you come
out there in not just saying we're gonna
we're gonna be anti-woke but in this
what i assumed was more of a niche
market and you just completely blow it
up so who are these customers
these are customers that i think have
felt just disenfranchised with where
entertainment in general is going and i
think it's just in entertainment all
together some of it's comic books of
course a lot of our guys are former
considering that i've been a commentator
in this space a lot of the guys that
like this material are going to be comic
book guys but we also got new customers
people that just see the direction of of
where entertainment's going you see what
rings of power seems about they're about
to do with tolkien you see uh what's
happening with star wars you see
basically every brand that a lot of us
have grown up on has been ran into the
absolute ground so for someone to come
by and say look i'm not really trying to
beat anybody's head over uh with
politics or anything not even my own you
know what i mean i'm just wanting to
give people material that they can be
entertained by kind of get lost in and
yeah it will expand into other types of
entertainment we're starting with the
books and these are just guys that
number one have money right they're
willing to spend not just people
retweeting stuff people that are willing
to spend money but i mean just look
around us and how everything's really
going in the toilet as of recent people
want something uh different and all i
did was give them a great granted i
spent a lot of money i got the best
artist that i possibly could and i made
this presentable because i it needed to
be comparable and they just came out in
full support and i think we're just
really just getting started well i like
that point that you're making there
because all the time
people pitch me on ideas they're always
you know because the daily wire is is
promoting content and so they'll say hey
i've got an idea for i say i'm going to
stop you right there because i don't
even want to hear the pitch because then
i'm legally liable if you so let's just
stop it right there do you have a
product that you're offering me or do
you have an idea and they always say
well no i got an idea i said well listen
man i'm lousy with ideas i have so many
i got ideas pouring out of my head
that's not what we need what we need is
really strong execution and so you put
your money where your mouth is you said
look i got a good idea for this comic
book i got a good idea for where the
marketplace is going to go but we can't
it's not enough to just say we're not
woke we're not we're not the left or
whatever you know and then and maybe
people give you a little bit of their
money for that but but what you're
saying is no we're going to make a very
very high quality product that happens
to not be left we're actually going to
compete on the level with these guys and
go toe to toe and you win
that's the
probably the most important part of it
like i put my money where my mouth was i
actually spent hundreds a couple of
hundred thousand dollars to just get the
bad boy off the ground paying my artist
gabriel taib clifford richards these are
people that have been in the game you
know for decades you know worked for the
big guys done that you know gabe was
being on star wars and superman and uh
you know we've we basically went
everywhere to to try to find
a group that we knew could make this
come to life but also we're just really
good at what it was that they did and
this isn't my first creative project i
mean i like to think of myself as a
decent writer but we put that all
together and we came up sort of with a
game plan to to all right let's make
something that's first and foremost
actually good right so it doesn't matter
let's say where this person is on the
political spectrum they see this cover
how they're going to feel about it they
start flipping through the pages how
they're going to feel about it i don't
want them to want it to feel cheap i
want it to feel like it's something
worth investing uh your money in because
i'm not old with these people's money
yeah if i landed with that putting a
point like i was oh man ty woke up i'm
it's a no whoa yeah i would have got a
couple of guys that would have lined my
pockets up but the fact that we said all
right here's the artwork you know here's
we've been very transparent about how
where it is that how these numbers are
lined up we've been very transparent
with uh you know give you the story we
give you the synopsis we give you the
breakdown of that we introduce you some
new new characters all of that and we
did it our own way put it on our own
website right not having to go through a
third party in order to do it kind of uh
uh making it to to look like we needed
it to look and people saw that finished
product and said you know what i want to
invest i want to pre-order i want to
give it a shot and i think that's where
a lot of creatives who are let's say
more so closer to our line of thinking i
think that's where they lose it people
come into it like i have an idea that of
of this type of entertainment but they
haven't even like actually made it come
into fruition to even present it as
something that's worth buying into and i
wanted to make sure that we did that and
this is why we're able to get the
pre-order out real relatively quickly it
just launched last month and it's going
to be out you know going into september
so it aligned perfect and i really took
this serious and i got the best in the
business to work with me now what makes
it non-woke because the libs always come
after us and they say you use this word
woke and we said well actually first of
all we got the word from you you guys
invented the word we just kind of throw
it back at you now you're running away
from it but they say you use this word
woke but what does it really mean you
know it's this catch-all buzzword and it
allows you to rally the troops and i
guess there's a point to that so what
what would distinguish these comic books
from say something that dc and marvel's
putting out see well a lot of these guys
are for one they're not creative at all
like they come into it leading with
their personal individual let's say
social political views let's say that uh
so when i think of wokeness i look at a
writer i look at a person that is
masquerading as a creative thinking that
first and foremost is about highlighting
what i individually believe from a
political or social uh more so from a
social view and it doesn't even matter
if it makes sense for that character
that all has already been long
established i am going to make sure i
write that into it so what they end up
doing is let's say using these
characters batman
superman some very prominent characters
as a vehicle
to uh basically spread whatever personal
social views that it is that they have
and we're not talking about things such
as like universal truths of good versus
evil which is really what what the comic
books had historically been about so
what i did was say you know what
everybody knows well i'm at i'm about
liberty you know what i mean it but
my idea of giving you a just a straight
up comic book isn't to beat you over the
head with everything it is that i
individually uh believe in i just want
you to be let's say entertaining yeah
under like the great stan lee once said
about social issues like he liked to put
it under laying the plot not to where it
felt like he was beating a reader over
the head well that's the complete
opposite of what guys are doing right
now they are not only beating you over
the head they're telling you that you
suck in the event that if you don't want
to buy into this well
this is what's remarkable to me to see
these massive companies have people that
represent them calling their fans actual
paying customers racist or homophobic or
or misogynistic which is one of their
favorite ones because god forbid you
don't like a female character see i'm
not interested in doing any of that i
think with these customers deserve some
sort of respect um because they don't
have to invest into this and i just
wanna i just wanna entertain you you're
not gonna just get an on the nose
political uh narrative with these books
or social political uh narrative with
these books just wanted to give you good
entertainment i really like this
distinction that you're making here
which is it's not
it doesn't make it woke necessarily if a
character espouses some left-wing
viewpoint because let's say you got some
super lib character in the in the book
and that's you know one of the defining
features of this character is he's a
super lib so then when he starts
spouting lib nonsense you would expect
that that would make sense but you're
saying it's it's when
it's it's when the lib nonsense
comes completely out of the blue and
especially with these characters who
have long established you know roles and
and traits in our conscience someone
like superman or batman or whoever when
all of a sudden they start sounding like
you know a 14 year old girl on tumblr in
2022 that all of a sudden you say hold
on wait that's not superman that's not
batman that's you the comic book maker
using my beloved character and taking
this beautiful piece of intellectual
property and just perverting it for your
own stupid political ends
and we saw that one of the big examples
of that with tim drake the robin in the
bat family where he just recently was
turned uh gay just to happen i mean
we've seen it it's visual like we know
that he's had girlfriends uh with like
spoiler and these other characters we
know that's a thing and that's part of
of him ice man that was a huge deal when
that happened with because this guy was
basically like a womanizer uh if
anything and then out of nowhere he's
just gay and they it's it's a form of
gaslighting because they act like none
of that material
exists but then you go look into like
the actual uh oftentimes it's like a
self-insert right it's uh it's a this
person was gay or uh this person had a
close gay family member or something and
they wanted to make sure that they use
this character to do that which is why
the writer tom taylor i believe is his
name for that like when superman's son
turned gay out of nowhere that was the
recent one uh when that happened i mean
the day that gets announced he's doing
interviews and he has that you know the
s on his chest and it's a rainbow like
it's a it's a rainbow s on his chest and
like dude you're telling me why you're
doing this that's exactly what what
you're why you're doing this you're
letting us know and that has turned so
many people off to what's happening with
the mainstream uh comic book industry
which is why we're thriving because i'm
simply just promising and we put out a
public code of ethics i want people to
hold me too i'm promising like hey i'm
not gonna be beating my audience over
the head but these things that people
care about more so from like the
continuity standpoint whether that be
with sexuality or anything it doesn't
matter what it is these are these are
our values with a company and i want
when you get isom number one you own a
piece of history not something that's
going to get retconned out of existing
because some writer just felt like well
i want him to be gay out of nowhere
something weird like that we're just not
interested in doing that i i like that
code of ethics i like that promise
because even this is getting really
weird now even beyond comic books and
and the superhero movies into james bond
who's who's kind of a superhero but he's
kind of like a normal hero superhero and
you're seeing a lot of continuity errors
there as well and rebooting and
restarting in ways that you hadn't seen
before and then to your exact point on
this after this last james bond movie
there was talk that their the next james
bond would be a woman
and my first thought was
no he won't because that wouldn't be
james bond because james bond is a dude
that's why his name is james so you can
have a spy lady movie but
that ain't going to be james bond and
but because they know that this content
won't stand on its own nobody's going to
go see
you know the brand new
here's your next double o agent spy lady
no one's going to go see spy lady so
what they've got to do or that no one's
going to go see come see super gay guy
no no one's going to do that so they got
to just take all the characters that you
do like and then shoehorn their own
their own agendas inside of that so on
your on your code of ethics for the for
the comic book beyond just you're not
going to be super didactic you're not
going to cram stuff down people's
throats
how does that even play on the on the
rebooting and the timelines and the
retconning
that's what the code of ethics about we
had like three main points and it really
doesn't even talk about like wokeness or
anything it's more of hey continuity is
a big thing a big thing that turned me
off from like modern comics was
that look man we have 16 reboots there's
55 different versions of the same
character you don't know what universe
that oh well that's batman but it's not
earth that's earth two batman or that's
our three like you know that's nonsense
and it really turns me turned me off
certainly as a reader i want to make it
easy for people so having i talked about
comprehensive timeline but main thing
like limit like the whole reboot thing
limiting all of that because again i
want people to get a book and they know
years down the line if we're still
continuing to tell a story those events
happen those are things that actually
happen it allows the reader to get
invested like why would i buy a dc book
when i know two years from now they're
gonna have some cataclysmic event and
it's gonna wipe everything that i just
read to where it does not happen good
luck and i say this is one of the
biggest batman fans that exists and i'm
i'm very knowledgeable on him i have to
come up with a freaking diagram to try
to make make it make sense when someone
asked me how i like batman i saw his
movie where do i start oh well
does this you want a batman but you
don't want to go to that issue one is
detective comics but that's you know it
got rebooted and then i have to try to
explain this to them because they
themselves have made a lot of continuity
issues so this is why i talk about like
a lot of this is my lifelong dream this
was always my lifelong dream to do this
it just kind of got sped up considering
my my recent like success and other
avenues but there are other issues that
were wrong with comics that also plague
it that yeah they may use sometimes
wokeness as a as a way to kind of put
this shoehorn and stuff in but those
aren't the only problems we found issues
in distribution of comics from an
economic perspective uh with uh diamond
basically in like two other public
distribu distribution houses that
basically control the entire industry
that didn't make any sense to me but
there's all sorts of things wrong with
comics um and i just want to instead of
always griping about the problem like i
have been doing for so long i want to be
a part of the solution that's great i i
love that idea and even your observation
on the rebooting it kind of ties in to
the
the lib woke view of the world which is
that history doesn't matter tradition
doesn't matter the past is always bad
and then you can just re remake the
whole world anytime you want whether
that's you know through the communist
revolution or whether it's by i don't
know changing your pronouns and chopping
off your body parts that you can just
constantly be remaking the world and i
wonder there there must be a relation
there and i love that you're saying
no we're actually going to respect our
readers we're going to respect the
characters we respect the narrative and
we're going to give you a high quality
product uh eric
since i think there isn't nearly enough
money we we've got to give get you to
five million or six million in sales
where can people get the comic
you can go to ripaverse.com uh if you
want to actually view of course the
company and everything it is that we're
we're doing the first book that you can
pre-order still right now there's 30
days left uh to get in on the pre-order
campaign ice some issue number one i
believe you guys are gonna love it it's
um about a character who by the name of
course i something that's a former hero
name he used to be a hero recently
retired and now there's this event that
is going to be bringing him into the
city that he likes to stay out of and
everything kind of hits the fan from
there so you can read the entire
synopsis uh breakdown kind of of the
story and there's so many different
items that you can get on on the isom
issue number one uh campaign just again
go visit ripperverse.com you can get in
and like i said fulfillment is about to
start in the next couple of weeks going
into september so get in where you can
fit in get in well you still can that's
great eric thank you so much for coming
on and congratulations on really
sticking it to all the woke people and
and making a good product in the process
appreciate you so much brother
[Music]
[Music]